ouais c'est quelqu'un va authentique je
pense que c'est le moment
constance spleen équilibre évidemment
c'est les valeurs qui ressort toujours
en panne de fleurs
on
oui je m'appelle florent fleurs en
bouquets en fait je viens de
sainte-marie l'île de la réunion en fait
dans l'océan indien installé au québec
depuis 15 ans charrie l'an 2000 en fait
à québec il ya des 10es au travail très
enthousiaste ray est très plaisant
côtoyé lors cessé je pense que les
studios quand on le voit soit en course
ces entrevues de course dans le domaine
de la course
c'est probablement l'un des studios dans
plusieurs domaines de la vie bon vivant
quelque chose faisons le dans la bonne
humeur parce que c'est plus bled comme
ça mais moi en fait je travaille pour
une multinationale qui s'appelle la bbc
groupe c n'ont plus de 100 pays dans le
monde ce qu'on fait ici c'est qu'on
manie facture on produit on fait la
recherche et développement on conçoit
donc des produits de mesures souvent à
base de technologies optiques
puis avec l'équipe on livre en fête pour
différentes industries donc ça va
d'industrie dans l'espace donc on va
avoir des censeurs conquis vol dans
l'espace avec des clients comme l'
agence spatiale canadienne les à la nasa
pour mesurer la couche d'ozone améliorer
les prédictions climatologiques des
mesures et les gaz à effet de serre
yann baky et j'aime beaucoup et le fener
la randonnée et la courbe dans les
montagnes comme caen lundi qu il faut
faire des jeux d ombres temps quelque
distance puis il préfère quand c'est
dans les montagnes jurassiennes des
rushes plutôt que sur le cancer
était venu au québec pour voir la neige
pour utiliser pour travailler mais pour
découvrir un pays nordique
puis effectivement je m'apprêtais à
partir pour l'europe et je les rencontre
est un pur dernier moment puis je me
suis dit c'est lui donc je sais que ça
valait la peine de changer les plans au
dernier moment
effectivement depuis on est resté ici et
on a frôlé la fin
investi énormément
partout ils pensent que ce soit au
travail que ce soit dans la famille et
soutien car d'avoir une vie sociale mais
avec des rapprochements très intime
c'est quelqu'un que l'on peut prendre
dans nos bras qu'on peut câliner qu'on
pouvait recevoir ce genre de personne
enfin comme les fans qui provoque les cc
pasly disque souvent un ballet j'avais
plein de problèmes pour mettre l'équipe
i s'impose non mais on est davis ça
c'est cool ce jeudi seuls donc la ja ja
stoner depuis d'une équipe en fait
d'ingénieurs depuis plusieurs années
puis d'après les témoignages que
j'entends c'est vraiment ce que les gens
apprécient et à l'écho depuis ils
emmènent les gens à se dépasser
eux-mêmes parce que ce qui fait pour
lui-même bah justement étant à mobiliser
les troupes huillard à mettre l'accent
je devrais sur le positif plutôt que de
mettre de l'énergie sur essayer de
régler tous ses défauts puis toutes ses
faiblesses pour tous de se dire ça vaut
plus la peine d'identifier ces forces
puis de mettre l'accent laxou de mettre
son énergie pour progresser pour
s'amuser sur cette page
notre dette du québec dans le fond mais
c'est pourquoi pourquoi use aussi
présents ici est sur le terrain c'est
pas seulement parce que par ses
performances loin de leurs c'est que
flora malgré ces performances restent
très accessibles et c'est ce qui fait je
pense qu'il dise pas plus là
si j'avais 80 alors assez l'homme on
doit qui nous vient d'une autre époque
et je fais la grosse marne
il ya beaucoup de poils
il ya des must c'est vraiment une bonne
corpulence en terme de moeurs mais
pourtant c'est l'homme au coeur avec
gardé son coeur d'enfant qui est
toujours prêt à aider ou à discuter avec
tout le monde
lorsque j'ai découvert à force de le
côtoyer c'est que c'est un père de
famille incroyable qui malgré tout on
aura de travail chargé malgré son
horaire d'entraînement aussi réussi à
concilier travail famille donc de
trouver l'équilibré dans six mois je
trouve et entraînement je trouve que
c'est un modèle à suivre sur bien des
points donc tant mieux s'il ya plus de
monde qui connaissent mon ami cela parce
qu'au début ça appartenant à
l'entraînement aujourd'hui je peux dire
c'est un très bon ami
on
voilà bryce canyon voilà trop vincent
machenaud courrent et là nous on est là
est à plat